le loisir aimerait bien rebondir à
l'urban je me demande pas l'ambiance est
plutôt morose avec les deux confinement
le site accuse 265 mille euros de perte
de chiffre d'affaires charles nature de
trois mois nous avons ouvert à la pire
période parce qu'il nous avons une
saisonnalité inversée l'été étant le
moins propice aux affaires et refermer
au moment où l'activité a été la
meilleure dans les villes très très mal
parce que bon déjà nous sont des lieux
de vie en effet habitude de vivre et là
c'est vraiment bon et ensuite au niveau
de l'entreprise
c'est une véritable catastrophe parce
que les aides sont certes importantes
ils sont neutres est très très très loin
du compte propriétaire de deux autres
structures de loisirs à maurepas
elancourt sébastien emploie 15 salariés
tous actuellement en chômage partiel
partout on entend parler du click and
collect qui est une manière de se
refaire un autre niveau
c'est impossible je ne peux pas sortir
pouvons-nous budget trampoline et puis
même si on avait vendre des places à
l'avancé
ce serait du chiffre d'affaires commente
ici près et qu'on ne ferait pas l'année
prochaine ce qu'ils utilisent
selon l'association professionnelle se
passe douze mille emplois directs sont
menacés avec une visibilité jusqu'au 31
décembre sébastien espère ne pas avoir à
définitivement baissé son rideau